hi in this video tutorial I would teach
you how to convert our grayscale image
into a colored image using image a so
the top priority for converting
grayscale into color image is it have to
be in either in two channels or three
channels or in a RGB mode so let's take
an example so we would open our desired
file and which is in a gray scale but
captured in RGB mode so here we have a
nuclear staining by Dappy ideally it
should be in blue but it's in a
grayscale now we would convert it into
blue so first we would go to image and
we would select the type by default you
can see the type is actually 8-bit so we
would change it and click on RGB color
after the RGB color is selected we would
again go to image and then color in the
color section you would find in the drop
down menu there is a option for make
composite when you make compose it you
would see now the three channels is
there so this is one of the way we can
achieve colors and after doing this what
we have to do again we would go to image
and then color and then we would split
the channels after splitting channel you
can see you get something in blue green
and red
so now Dappy would show you in blue and
you want to give a blue color over here
so that is why you would choose the blue
one right and you would cancel all other
channels after doing this you can right
click on it and or you can just go to
file and you could save it you could
save it in a desired location so you can
write color image and save so by doing
this method we can convert a grayscale
into a colored image and but remember
this would be only valid for a RGB image
or any image which is in three channel
or at least in
two channels right okay if you like my
video then give it a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe please leave
your comments below thank you